we told you that bank of america has
been turning over private customer data
to the feds as part of its effort to
defeat extremism now we're learning that
bank of america itself has extremist
views bank of america is teaching its
employees that toddlers can be racist
according to bank of america quote
toddlers develop racial biases by ages
three to five and should be actively
taught to recognize the smog of white
privilege obviously
that's like the creepiest scariest most
evil thing we've read today chris ruffo
broke this story
good for him he joins us tonight chris
thanks so much for the reporting that
you do this is shocking
bank of america is endorsing this
yeah that's right in their training
program that they recommended employees
take over 21 days it's really a race
free education program
bank of america which in its very name
claims to represent the united states
denounces america as a white supremacist
country and by extension expresses
antipathy and even hatred to 70 of its
citizens but unfortunately this is a
pattern across many of our fortune 100
companies uh they've adopted programs
that are indistinguishable from the most
radical critical race theory courses in
our elite universities
i mean
what do they say what you know they're
teaching people that white children are
inherently evil and racist and their
employees just kind of sit there and nod
i mean is is anybody saying you know i'm
not putting up with this anymore you ca
if you said this about any other group
it would be unacceptable why are you
doing this does anyone fought back
you know from the sources who leaked me
this material they fought back through
me by sharing the documents with me so i
could expose them to the public but
here's the thing in corporate america
people are scared for their jobs they're
scared for their reputations they're
scared for their families this is the
new dominant ideology in workplaces and
universities in k through 12 schools
people are terrified to stand up because
they see that americans who do stand up
for the very simple truth that we should
be all be treated equally regardless of
our skin color is are now treated as
enemies of our largest institutions
they'll be held up for mockery shame
humiliation
and it's up to us to stand up to speak
out those of us who have a platform who
have power
because this ideology is seeping into
our institutions and seeks to subvert
and destroy the very foundational
values and principles of this great
country
yeah i mean we're turning into rwanda
tootsies hutus this is really sick and
you've been brave and relentless in
exposing i appreciate it chris ruffo
thank you
thank you